- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
of the major problems in the world.
So, to help you on your journey,
today we're going to talk about
how you can find your purpose.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
you might win a prize, too.
And also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat intro music)
- If I said to you that
you can have any one thing,
you can have good health,
you can have money,
you can have the fame that
allows you to inspire people.
What would you choose as a one thing?
- Certainly, I think without
health, you're not around
to do anything.
But I think it's a life of meaning.
I don't think, I know it is.
Feeling like your life matters,
because you've had the experience.
You and I both have lots of friends
who've achieved everything they
could ever have dreamed of,
and they're miserable.
I get the phone call to
help turn them around.
They're missing a meaningful life
and meaning comes from two things.
I always tell people
happiness comes from progress.
If you can do something
where you're growing
and because you've grown
you have something to give
to other people that's meaningful,
insight, love, caring, something,
then life is rich.
Because happiness comes and goes.
Happiness is not here every moment
and happiness isn't all
it's cracked up to be.
Meaning is.
There are people that have
gone through horrible times.
I met a woman who is 109 years old
and she was in the concentration camps,
and is the oldest-living
Holocaust survivor.
And that woman's life is so
rich because of all the pain,
because she's used that to help
other people, still at 109.
She's strong, you know,
she shares her music.
She does the things
that make her feel like
she's got a contribution.
So 109, she's fully alive.
- Who did you help?
I mean, I really believe
that what life is truly about
is making other people happier.
And I know that sounds very obvious,
but this does apply to
you as an entrepreneur,
or as a leader, or as a high-performer,
or as someone who wants
to play at world-class.
I mean, I really believe in this concept
of servant leadership.
And as I've studied
the great entrepreneurs
and the great business builders
and the great humanitarians,
here's what I've realized.
Inside, sometimes it was very private,
on this second point
of the purpose of life,
they had this acute obsession
with delivering value
and helping as many people as possible.
And I really do believe
that's the secondary purpose of life.
It's about helping others.
Being radically helpful to
as many people as possible.
And here's the thing.
If you've done the interior work,
so you are so full there's
no holes within you,
then you're not going to
be a taker from the world,
you're going to be a giver.
And I'm going to repeat that again.
If you look at the greatest among us,
they were not takers, they were givers.
And here's why I think they were givers.
They didn't have any needs from within.
They had so fallen in
love with their greatness
and their peace and their
joy and their potential
that they didn't need
to take from the world,
they didn't need to
take from other people.
Their well of wisdom and compassion
and self-worth was so full
that they walked out into their workplace,
they walked out into their industries,
they walked out into their communities,
and they were giving.
And this applies to you
as a business builder
because the more value you give,
the more money you'll make,
the more your brand will fly,
the more customers will beat
a path to your doorstep.
And for you as a humanitarian,
and you might not think of
yourself as a humanitarian,
but a humanitarian is simply someone
that cares about humanity.
And as a humanitarian, the more you give,
the more you will open up
the doorways to receive
from the rest of the world.
- If you live in your gift,
you find your purpose.
The two greatest days of your
life is the day you were born
and the day you discover why.
And it ain't too old to discover why.
See, Kentucky Fried Chicken.
You ever notice the picture of that man
up there on that wall?
He old.
You know, that ain't the
picture of him when he was 20.
That's the picture of him when he hit.
See, Kentucky Colonel been
frying that chicken all his life.
It ain't hit 'til he was 68-years-old.
So, what you trippin' for?
'Cause you 50, you 55?
You don't know when God going
to flip the script for you.
But you can't give up.
But you got to be doing your gift.
Don't quit going to work,
man, without doing your gift.
And some of you all fry
chicken better than anybody,
some of you all bake pie,
some of you all do hair,
some of you do makeup, some of
you all work with your hands,
some of you all cut grass,
some of you all teach better,
some of you all network better.
That's your gift, go do that.
Go do that, what you
driving to work for everyday
and you ain't happy with yourself?
Why, 'cause you got bills?
You going to have bills,
I don't care what you do.
What you going to mess your credit up?
Then you can't buy nothing no how.
- That you know while we are all unique,
we all share similarities.
All human cultures across the span of time
have been found to truly value
very simple, basic things.
You know, love, truth,
fairness, freedom, unity,
respect, responsibility, and tolerance.
And as we recognize those,
now not all of them exuded it great,
but as a part of their culture,
there was the operating norm
that valued those types of things.
Something connects us.
It's a human fabric of
values and of beliefs
that usually center around
caring and compassion and love
and truth with one another
because that's what keeps us all together.
And that is what not only
helped us survive at one point,
but more importantly, it made
us feel spiritually fulfilled.
Love is a purpose.
Love has been argued to be the purpose
by a whole lot more smart
and intelligent persons
than the guy you're
listening to right now,
I can tell you that.
But if that's true,
if connection, love is so vital,
how are we doing in those categories?
Are we living purposefully
with the people around us?
Or are we even sensing and seeing them
so that we can connect with
them and live out that purpose
and sense that purpose by really
connecting with the people
that we truly love and adore?
A lot of people are so distracted today,
they can barely even look
at somebody in the eye
when they walk down the street.
You know, they're looking,
I don't like this.
They can't even pay
attention to their spouse
or their lover when they
walk into the house.
I mean, they're distracted,
they are detached,
and they are dissipating in life energy
because they are not giving and receiving
that incredible energy
that can only happen
between two human beings.
And so we have to ask how are
we doing in our relationships
and could we give more
purpose to those relationships
so they can sense more purpose in life?
- I don't think you determine
what your purpose is,
I think you discover what your purpose is.
There's a difference.
Determining indicates deciding.
And I don't think you decide.
I think if you go about it the right way,
you discover it.
Like, there's some people that
should be painting all day.
They're great artists.
Like Michelangelo was
obviously a great artist,
a great sculptor.
I mean, that was his purpose
in his life.
Well, I believe my purpose
is doing what I'm doing.
Your purpose is why you get
out of bed in the morning.
Do you know why you get up?
Well, most people say,
"Well, it's to go to work."
Well, that'd be a good
reason to stay in bed.
You say, "Well, everybody's doing it."
That'd be another reason to stay in bed.
If you're ever doing
what everybody's doing,
you're probably going
in the wrong direction.
Your purpose is your reason for living.
What you want to do is sit down
and maybe take a pen and a pad
and then ask yourself, "What
do I really love doing?"
Now, you may have to
spend a while at this.
You might get up an
hour early every morning
and go sit under a tree somewhere
if you're in a nice climate
or pick a favorite chair,
some place where you're
not going to be disturbed.
And totally relax and say,
"If I could spend my life doing something,
"what do I really love doing?"
Now, since you don't ask
yourself that question everyday,
it might take a while for this answer
to come to the surface,
but it comes to your consciousness.
And it may take a while.
You may have to do this every
morning for three months,
but it would be well-invested, the time.
- What lights you up in the morning?
What would get you up
early and keep you up late?
Ask questions like, "If I
could only spend my life
"doing one thing, what would it be?
"If I had to actually pay
to do something as a job,
"what would it be?"
And start getting in touch
with that part of you
that is compelled to do things
that align with your truth,
rather than fit somebody else's pictures
or run after somebody else's dreams
and help them achieve their goals,
which, unfortunately, most people do.
So, once you've found
out what your passion is,
the next step to deepen that
is to get a big enough why.
Not a what, a why.
Why is it you're doing this?
Because, again, if it's to get approval,
if it's to get significance,
if it's to be liked or loved,
that's very shallow and very short-term.
And it's a hamster wheel
to nowhere for most people.
Instead, the people who
are the most passionate,
the people that have the biggest why's
usually focus on something
that is beyond themselves.
Do you have somebody you love
that you want to provide a future for
that you can share together
that comes from abundance nor scarcity?
Do you want to be able
to provide opportunities
for your children that you never had?
Do you want to create a
mark and leave a legacy
in your community or your country
that most people will never be able to do?
That takes a level of
commitment and courage
that serves beyond our own ego.
You get in touch with that part of you,
the dream, the truth that
you were born to do and be,
and I guarantee you, passion
will not be far behind.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video,
what did you take from it,
if you're going to immediately
apply it to your life
or to your business somehow.
Please share, leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Brandon Hood
from on2purpose.
What's up, Purpose Nation?
Thank you so much, Brandon,
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and doing the review on
your YouTube channel.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate your support, too.
Thank you so much and I'm
glad you enjoyed the book.
- This book does a great job
explaining why it's important
to discover your one word.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, have an amazing
day and I'll see you soon.
- So when you talk about
making your dash dance.
Point one, you got to be
willing to do it afraid.
See you might be waiting
for the fear to stop,
"Lisa, I heard this so many times.
"Lisa, I'm afraid, what do I do?"
Do it anyway.
"Lisa, I'm afraid I don't
quite know if I should move."
Move anyway.
"I don't know if I should leap."
Leap afraid.
And then gather your
courage on the way down.
And if you don't get it before you hit,
you was going to hit anyway.
I'd rather die leaping than
on the edge figuring out how
to get the courage to leap.
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- Yes, yes?
- So many times, we're waiting.
We're waiting, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting to get something right.
I see your hands going up, you guys know.
If it's your truth,
you can raise your hand
just like we did on day zero.
You're just kind of waiting.
You're waiting to get everything in order.
You're waiting, you're
waiting so that everything
that's in you is together.
You're waiting to not be afraid.
You're waiting to have the courage.
You're waiting to have all the money.
You're waiting to lose weight.
See, if I waited to
release my unwanted pounds
before I got in front of you,
Lisa Nichols would be the secret.
(laughter)
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- I thought, how about I just
leap with my imperfection
and then find my form of
perfecting my imperfection
while I'm soaring?
How about I do that?
How about you not wait to get it right?
You figure out how does
it look doing it wrong.
How does that look?
Because your 80% of right
is somebody else's 159%
of what they needed.
Yes, yes?
- [Audience] Yes, yes.
- And when you want to do it right,
and you want to wait
'til you're not afraid,
and you want to wait 'til
you have it all together,
oh, you made it about you.
Again.
See, Nelson Mandela did it.
He just did it not
knowing if it were right.
Mahatma Gandhi just did it
not knowing if it were right.
Mother Teresa just did it
not looking for affirmation
or confirmation, is this right?
Martin Luther King did it not even knowing
if it would happen before his life ended.
I mean, what are you waiting on?
Are you willing to do it afraid?
Are you willing to do it knowing
that you got so much work
to do to get it better,
to get it more perfect,
but are you willing to do
it inside your imperfection?
Do you realize that in your imperfection,
you're perfect for the job?
- Who did you become?
I mean, did you use your days as platforms
for further greatness?
Did you use your days to transcend fear
towards fearlessness?
Did you use your days,
even the hard times,
so that you leveraged
suffering into wisdom?
Did you use the moments of your life
to develop wisdom, compassion,
to become more creative,
to release potential?
Who did you become?
That's really the first
purpose of life, I believe.